The previous video got us introduced to Meiosis!It
is defined as an exceptional
phenomenon which produces FOUR daughter cells,
each with half the number of
chromosomes, compared to the single parent
cell!
Meiosis is a process that gives rise to a
haploid cell from diploid one.
We have
seen these definitions!
Now before moving ahead with the actual process,
let us
halt at the question that we left you with
in the previous video!
We need to know, which are the reproductive
cells that we have been talking
about so far?
Which are the cells with half the number of
chromosomes?
Let us understand that first!
The Egg cell of female and Sperm cell of male,
are haploid cells which unite to
form a Zygote.
And these haploid cells together are called
“Sex cells” or “Gametes
or even Germ cells”.
Now let us understand how these gametes are
produced with the help of
Meiosis!!
Just like mitosis, the cell during meiosis,
also goes through a number of
orchestrated steps.
So does that mean Meiosis is just like Mitosis?
Kind of...!
Meiosis is a lot like mitosis, but they have
some major differences as well.
Let us list down the similarities between
Mitosis and Meiosis first!
The cell goes through similar stages and uses
the same strategies to organize and
separate chromosomes.
It goes through the Interphase for its growth
and DNA
replication.
Later, it enters the dividing stage that is
Karyokinesis followed by
Cytokinesis!
Both the processes require ample amount of
time to prepare for the
actual division.
These were the similarities between the two
processes.
Now what could be the differences between
them?
Let us have a glance at them.
In meiosis, the cell has a more complex task
to perform.
Don’t worry ...This
doesn’t mean that these tasks are difficult
to study.
The tasks are difficult for the
cells, not for us!
They are way too simple if you understand
the concept well.
Let us get to know
these tasks!
We know that mitosis involves four stages
for cell division!
Can you try and
recollect the four stages of mitosis?
That’s a right answer!
They are Prophase,
Metaphase, Anaphase and Telophase.
On similar lines, meiosis also has four
stages for cell division.
But here, the slight difference is that meiosis
is carried out
in two rounds or steps.
That is, Meiosis is divided into “Meiosis-one”
and
“Meiosis-two” as two major phases.
But why do cells need two rounds of division
here?
The simple answer is, we need four daughter
cells with half the number of
chromosomes each!
So the first step gives us two cells, which
divide further to
give the four cells.
Technically speaking, the first round separates
the homologous chromosomes,
while the second round separates the sister
chromatids from each other.
We are familiar with the terms “homologous
chromosomes”, and sister
chromatids...right?
But let us revise them, once!
The term “homologous” means the ones having
the same relation, position or
structure.
So here, it represents the two chromosomes
forming a pair.
In other words, when we say a “pair of chromosomes”,
we actually address a pair
that has one chromosome from mom, and one
from dad.
But can any two
chromosomes form a pair?
No!
The chromosomes forming a pair should be same
in size, structure, length and even the loci
of their genes.
Thus, only similar ones
can form a pair!
So homologous chromosomes mean the set of
twin chromosomes, obtained one
from mom and one from dad!
The next term is “sister chromatids”.
In this single chromosome structure, these
two thread-like arms attached to this central
bulge called “centromere” are called
the sister chromatids.
This sister chromatid is like an exact copy
of this one, as it
contains the replicated DNA.
Now getting back to the division process!
In order to carry out the separation of
homologous chromosomes and then the sister
chromatids, the cell has to
undergo two rounds of division.
So the cell first enters meiosis-one!
Here it begins
with an amazing new journey of division involving
four stages namely Prophase-
one, Metaphase-one, Anaphase-one and Telophase-one!
Let us learn about them
in detail in the next video!